okay counselors it's my pleasure to
welcome you along to this extraordinary
meeting off Council we have two items on
the agenda one an open agenda and one in
committee so just coming firstly to
apologies
is there anyone here that we need to
register or anybody that we need to
register an apology for I understand
Stewart is going to be late to tender
there's anybody else don't think
everybody else is here but somebody
you'd like to move that that apology be
sustained please John and sick and an
evil thank you all those in favor please
say aye
against the motion is carried thank you
okay so we'll move on then to item 2
which is the proposed code 19 short-term
rates 2 3 all policy and all counselors
will be welcome along sure all
counselors will be well aware that there
are some within our community that are
really feeling the pinch in terms of
something financially given the
challenges of this particular emergency
and I think it behooves us to look at
ways that we can help in any way we can
and the chief executive has done quite a
bit of work in the last few days just
looking at how we might be able to make
some refinements to our rates policy
particularly referring to covert 19 and
two to give some assistance and for
those who who may need that assistance
over the next six month period but Steve
can I just turn it up to you do you want
to talk about so what this policy is and
then we'll open it for questions
thank you worship is that the policy is
actually first I need to emphasize that
is subordinate a complementary to the
council's remission of rate policy which
is contained in our current long-term
plan to amend the overarching remission
rates policy would require consultation
the public and consultation is not
something this counts for shiz away from
but of course we're in a situation of
economic and health crisis and the
council is being asked to see if it can
offer some type of relief to rate payers
who are facing rate instalments notices
very shortly so hence the the approach
we've taken is to try and see if we can
work within the existing policy
framework to avoid having to consult so
we can offer something up to ratepayers
right here and now almost in an
instantaneous way so as my report says
it's not with the benefit of lots of
reflection and time but it's trying to
as basically I are able of some forms of
relief so we have been able to and the
IT team have been really great to be
able to offer up a an online option with
hopefully what is deemed to be a
user-friendly form the policy is
designed to be specifically referred to
covert 19 and offer us up to two
quarters or two rexis formants that can
be deferred important to understand for
anyone perhaps listening in future time
is that this is not a rate remission
it's a deferral and so the council does
expect that it will receive rates but in
the fullness of time and the council
would work with the rate payers who come
through the application process
and to work out a payment plan that is
sustainable and acceptable to both
parties the the 31 August timeline for
the proposed expiry of the policy is so
that the Arizona literally offered two
quarter two quarters worth of payments
that can be deferred and then with a few
more months under our belt and rigor in
regard to both what lies ahead of us but
what has come behind us when we get
towards that date the council will have
a bit of time to actually be able to
think about a more expensive policy
package that may want to
in town and uh so it would need to
factor in the requirement to consult
with the public so it's you worship the
staffs beast assessment of what we can
do to make some of the instant pain go
away for a while and hopefully it
release some burdens of everyday living
from ratepayers but it does still
require that those ratepayers commit to
a payment plan and stick with it but say
we've managed to be able to construct
this so that it's not in violation of
the main policy the policy does
crucially provide for one rates penalty
per rate pair to be remitted to enemy
and because this particular time was
peddling two financial years were able
to offer up this policy package without
breaching their overarching main policy
so I think that's about it the worship
we've tried to be as simple as possible
hopefully we've got there but very happy
to receive suggestions from Linda Mills
about the adequacy the reach and the
messaging that comes with it mrs.
Gillick and the communications manager
will be able to provide a commentary
about the type of communications plan
that we've got really two to deliver
with us and support this proposal and we
have staff on standby to receive phone
calls when it goes live on Friday if in
print thank you Steve for the
explanation I and I think it it
absolutely makes sense and I just think
yeah you and staff who have worked on
this over the last few days to to bring
it to the conclusion that you here so we
all counselors have a copy of of the
proposal before them it comes with two
appendices the first the finished one
and to really refer to our current rate
permission policy and then we're looking
at three and four for the deferral
policy so without too much further ado
I'll open that up for discussion and any
questions or comments from counselors
so Glynnis you had your own nucleus I
have two questions will the rates 2/3 be
in full because the remission policy
says that it doesn't include the three
waters in the waist and the other
question I hear this will DB capacity in
their policy giving effect to those who
are paying rates as part of the rental
agreement because some of those
businesses could have had losses I'm
thinking of like the hospice that pays
pays rates but then the landlord as part
of their agreement with the landlord I
guess was just a number of items and/or
points in that question but just want to
make it clear again and Steve's already
done that that we're talking about a
deferral policy here and not the
remission policy so we do need to be
clear that there are two separate
policies and they'll stand alongside
each other but not replacing each other
so Steve do you want to answer those
questions you know I think you used to
worship I think you've asked the first
one that it is remission so sorry it's
not remission mr. Farrell before you can
defer your entire Anders policy rates
installment both the fourth quarter for
the current year and the first
installment for the next year completely
and put it on to a time payment plan to
say action of the council's rating staff
this policy is only open to the rate
payer so but that doesn't say that for
example if someone is a lessee in a
commercial lessee and under the
commercial lease that lessee pays the
rates and that's quite often the case in
commercial leasing that tenant or lessee
would be eligible for relief under this
policy thank you
you thinks your worship yo I think it's
a good policy I suppose the only point
I'd like to make is we're in
extraordinary times and and many of the
people impacted by this won't be used to
asking so I'm quite keen to see
evidential aspects of the policy removed
and just replace for the declaration so
someone's prepared to the clear that
they've got financial hardship and be
paid did they clear that they had a loss
of employment to me that's enough we're
not giving the rights away we're just
deferring them so I'd like to suggest
anyway that if we could you know page 12
and 30 and if we refers to evidence of
that we could become a declaration of
financial hardship or a declaration of
loss of employment I think they said
time were an especially ever in a an
online application so Steve does that is
that still possible with them the policy
if it gained supporter and there's some
legal aspects that would drive us to
mediator them through your worship
no there's nothing legal and changes
impediment getting the road and
permitting that we gave it some weeding
the staff gave it some consideration and
I guess we were just what not wanting to
create a loophole where someone might
say well I'll just have a six month
holiday it's young what a good idea when
their pets don't need it so on balance
we thought some evidence of hardship
without being honest would have would be
the way to go but guarded by the council
there's no there's no legal impediment
to changing it as you you know thank you
I take your point I guess yeah it would
be a in this interest rate environment
that be hardly much advanced to to try
and screw the scrum on rate but my view
be interested now the council is you
yeah I think you raise a good point
bread and and I think the response has
been been a good one from from achieving
theatre as well but I see the Brahmin
did you want to ask something on this as
well you think you you worship and I
agree with bridge on this one I think
maybe people it would be a big issue for
some people to even put the hand up to
say that they're struggling financially
and you know really the government
didn't ask for a lot of information or
requirements around the payments that
they made and I think it would be really
good if we could explore that and maybe
come up with that and the other point
I'd like to make to uh it's nice to see
that the penalties would be dropped I
think that's a really good move as well
so I think that should be also front and
foremost when that's being laid out to
the public that no penalty supplies
thank you okay so before we go on any
further discussion around evidence as
opposed to declaration which have been
well made you should worship the quality
it's desirable not to require evidence
right I think the key word the chief
executive uses is some evidence about
the impact of code without being owner s
I think one has to remember that those
people who are not going to take
advantage of the Thoreau policy will in
fact be caring other members for a short
time and that's fine so I think we've
got to be just use a little bit just
distribution but once again the key
words are evidence without being onerous
and it's an opportunity for counsel to
demonstrate that the human face yeah
thank you
against the Bulger case the grant Doug
thanks your worship you know I agree
with Brit and also Brahman I do yeah if
you're gonna put your hand up you know
you're actually in trouble I don't
believe that this is going to be used
there will be there are people out there
that are hurting right now people have
lost their jobs but also yes we'll get
going forward a little bit through that
there will be businesses that are
struggling there will be employers they
have to lay people off and also
and just another having to show it I
don't believe we need to have a huge
form-filling exercise or anything like
that or even having to have the
interviews if you just sign the
agreement say listen I really would need
to defer my rights for the next 1/4 or
two quarters we every which way you want
to do it I think that should be enough
that's just my opinion
okay any questions comments Richard I
just just to regard the policy well
they're good policy with reference to
relating to whether we need a step there
call that down even some hardship
obviously desert well see component it
would still be the understanding of the
rate payers of looking at people making
application or keeping facility give
will be obviously looking it and these
applications he's thinking worship I'll
agree with Brits stance I think that if
people are going to apply they're going
to already be at a disadvantage and I
don't believe we should make them go
through too many hoops to you know to
progress this so I would I'd be in favor
of not too many requirements around
proof of or such like so it would be my
stance thank you I threw you worship I
just think because it's a deferral and
not a remission of rates that we don't
need to be to owners about
but one question I would raises that
just counsel need to be accountable for
the rates to feel well do we need to
have a criteria to meet like people's
finances just so that we are accountable
to the to the ratepayers that we are
deferring rates for the right reasons
look I think that's pretty laid it
pretty well laid out in paper you've got
before you I'm just not sure what what
more we could ask for there if we want
to be a little bit flexible and agile
and and the way we go about this but
open for suggestions I'm just not quite
sure where to from here with it their
suggestion okay
council
I think he you worship I just reiterate
what what the other council have said in
regards to the policy and I think it's a
good policy just that I think while it's
been recorded there perhaps Steve could
pass on his surance that the council
itself is in a financial position to be
able to do this at the moment and we
know burden on the on right Paris
further down the track you wanna make
some comment dear student
yeah thank you look this is a stiffened
the unknown in terms of the type of
uplift of this policy that we may
receive but we this way of he might be
slightly in importance and it may be
necessary to borrow short term to cover
the amount that we may not take in a
race in those two quarters that said
having talked spoken with a management
count today she's pretty she's pretty
comfortable because we've drawn down
some funds for forthcoming capital
we should be able to manage this without
the need for doing fear their short-term
borrowing in hints it's obviously
requires a lot of gift and skilled
management by staff to monitor payment
repay plans and make sure that they are
adhered to and ultimately that the funds
that we need to deliver the services do
have each they win their way back into
the council system okay thank you your
worship here that definitely answers the
question and gives also an understanding
to the other right pirates that may be
watching this that yeah we're doing
everything we could possibly can to for
up for a complete yeah okay and is there
any further question or comment I've got
some hands up the Richard is it one from
before and nibble mine samba4 takes us
and John Council guard on John it's good
good policy and I think the secret will
be in discretion by the staff and I'm
gonna strain this one and you know were
spread those payments over a longer term
depending on the situation and I think
that'll be easily summed up in a
gentleman cord
Nora great thanks
thank you counsel read from your on need
from I beg your pardon
and think she'll worship the other thing
that I would maybe the the people who
are talking to their rate payers who
apply for this maybe they would should
also mention the rates rebate because
because of income loss or something they
may find that they are eligible for that
as well and that may defer a payment for
them it may not be all of it but because
it's a sliding scale there should be
eligible for some any further comment or
question I get the sense that there's
a mood to change the wording from
evidence to declaration is does that
require an amendment you want me to go
through an amendment or so general
agreement was that anybody Gandhi posted
there and to it you want to make comment
you worship yeah right nah no I'm happy
were happy with that
Traci I was just acknowledging I was
happy with it by putting the piano right
so Elsa boldly who I'm opposed to that
change in wording on certainly fully
supportive of the policy and you know
I'm not going on at the chair thinking
against Roger so if there's no further
questions or comments councillor Reid
you still put your hand up with
something else or was it just okay and
thank you and if there is no further
comments and was that one change around
the wording evidence being replaced by
declaration would somebody like to move
the policy that you have before you
council Davis don't seconder
Stuart thank you right
is there any discussion before I put
that motion there's not a cut the motion
all those in favor please say oh I
raised your hand q against unanimous the
motion is carried
Thank You counselors and I look I think
that we've made a really good step here
and that there will be some people that
find some will benefit from us and and
it's just good to see that that council
is prepared to respond quickly and with
empathy to the way that people will be
feeling as we go into the the next phase
of this particular
challenge ahead of us okay so we move on
now to item 3 which is a piece of
business that needs to be discussed in
committee it is a piece of business
looking at rubbish recycling waste
management and just some rethinking
around that and the reason for going
into inter committee is for maintaining
legal privilege and to enable the local
authority holding the information to
carry on without prejudice disadvantage
negotiations including commercial and
industrial negotiations so I'm going to
move that council now moves into
committee do I was second to all that
obviously which council Bolger thank you
is there any discussion